The Joe Rogan Experience yeah where does
our guilt extend
like if we Outsource all the things that
we're guilty about does it leave at our
border like never it never leaves yeah
you have a phone that's made by slaves
but do you feel guilty about it yes you
do yeah for sure if there was a company
that came along that was like if Samsung
said hey we're gonna make all of our
phones cruelty free cruelty free we're
gonna get all of our Cobalt from this
place where we can ensure you that
there's nothing there and and no uh
Chinese Factory workers making you know
16 cents a day or whatever the [__] they
make yeah it's not if yeah if there's a
phone that was made in America that cost
twice as much I'd buy it in a [__]
heartbeat but there isn't there isn't
and because there isn't we what do we do
we put up with the guilt like well they
[__] up they [__] us okay and you
know to to to be connected to something
where you absolutely absolutely need it
but it's morally reprehensible at its
very core
like imagine how many people have
tweeted self-righteous things on a phone
that was made by slaves
that's that's the reality of these
phones and Apple's one of the richest
[__] companies on planet Earth I
don't know what the logistics would be
involved in making a phone in America
with skilled labor that gets paid a fair
wage and gets health insurance and Union
benefits and all that stuff but whatever
it is I feel like I would like to pay
that and we have maybe and if I don't
have the money I'll buy less phones I'll
buy a phone I have a [__] iPhone 11
one of my phone lines is an iPhone 11.
it's great it still works yeah still
seems so normal when I fire it up it
doesn't seem any different to me but do
we have the mineral like do we have
Cobalt in America that we can mine I
don't think we do that's the tricky
thing I don't know is Cobalt um
available I thought it's only available
in like the Congo well that's where the
primary source is for sure but I think
there's at least one other place on
Earth
I don't remember correctly
oh Mexico let's go let's go listen we
have a problem with the cartels why
don't you just let's just like Mexico do
we have a problem with them
do we have a problem with the cartels or
are we working with a cartel well for
sure someone's working with them
I mean it's not just like 100 Mexican
citizens that are sneaking across here
and doing all this business
someone's working with them
God damn what is wrong with my throat
um
yeah someone for sure is working with
them
um but it's not good it's not good to
have this like fake scenario you have a
fake scenario say drugs are bad if you
make drugs illegal no one's going to do
drugs like your math sucks okay because
that's not the correct math the correct
math is if you make drugs illegal then
illegal people sell drugs you [__]
[__] and so now you've propped up a
multi-billion dollar industry South of
the Border filled with ruthless
murderers Idaho is the only Cobalt mine
in the United States and it's going to
remain so okay so we have some Cobalt
here I'm sure they could find some more
maybe we have just enough for us how
about just for us let's like let the
world make their own moral decisions but
maybe if we we legitimately are the
moral High Ground we could like
encourage the rest of the world to
realize like the same thing we were
talking about earlier about having too
much money like just don't you can't
just think about money at a certain
point in time you you have to just
figure out what's best for everybody yes
and in this situation if I was the king
of the world if I was the king of
America I would say how about we only
make phones that are in America yep we
make American-made phones with American
we'll have sanitary conditions that are
safe and you know provide Health Care
all the things that you would hope
someone working a [__] Cobalt mine
would get give them a great wage like
make it so that this is an even exchange
it's not a negative exchange protect
them from all the if we knew that the
Cobalt were getting on our phone you
don't have to worry these guys make a
hundred thousand dollars a year they're
[__] well paid they're they they live
in a great Community okay great now I
don't feel bad about my phone but if you
watch those videos from Foxconn you see
those [__] poor people
slaving away all day long in this
Sweatshop 16 hours a day they have bunks
there and [__] they put Nets around the
building to keep people from jumping off
that is so wild instead of changing the
conditions
that's crazy they're like get back to
work yeah grab you by your hair [__]
drag you back down onto the floor you
probably owe them money or something I
mean I don't know how they [__] do
that
oh yeah it's a tricky one you would you
would want everything you use in your
everyday life to have a clean connection
to like ethically sourced materials you
know great relationships with workers no
greedy corporations that are [__]
over the environment everybody would
want that I think they'd want that if
they had excess I think most people are
like trying to pay their [__] rent
and they're like all right if this is a
little bit cheaper I have a little bit
more money for my family my my parents
who are sick and my kids like I can buy
them another [__] baseball mitt and
so they can't even consider people in
the Congo and I think that's the tricky
thing where like they know it's almost
like uh the the the Amazon situation
where it's like most people probably
know that Amazon might not be the best
situation for like mom and pop
businesses but it's so convenient to
them and it's so much cheaper and it's
so efficient that they just go all right
well this is great for me yeah yeah
there's that that
the the
it is interesting but I think that in
those circumstances when you know
there's people that just can't afford to
buy you know whatever it is ethically
sourced and organically grown that there
should be other options but if there was
a clear option that someone could take
if a phone costs
thousand twelve hundred bucks right this
article I just looked up uh as saying
that cell phones are not what's driving
the Cobalt price rise it is the price
rise batteries it's quite batteries but
yeah well that was the Teslas and [__]
but that but that is what they use them
in cell phones it's like Lithium-ion
batteries eight grams of cobalt is in a
cell phone
and how much is in like a nine volt
battery
uh
yeah
but a rechargeable battery that's okay I
I see your point you're right it's like
um it's everything Electronics we're
thinking about it as cell phones but
that's because cell phones are the
primary they're just dominated
communication and just just how many
podcasts are listened to on cell phones
all of them yeah or is it like 90 like
if imagine if cell phones were made
illegal and people still had to get
podcasts done
the majority of modern electric vehicles
use these battery chemistries and
lithium nickel magnesium magnets like
manganese manganese Cobalt oxide
and which have a cathode containing 10
to 20 Cobalt and what was the cell phone
eight grams eight grams but that's a
different measurement unit right one of
them is percentage yes one of them is
grams
either way I mean it's it's like it's
kind of for everything with lithium ion
batteries it does something to stabilize
it you know what it's like it's like
it's almost like asking 4 to 30
kilograms for a UV five percent okay
cell structure requires a minimum amount
of cobalt about five percent unless
lower energy density lithium ion
batteries without Cobalt are used at the
expense of performance a typical
smartphone battery requires only five to
twenty grams of cobalt whereas an EV
requires between 4 and 30 kilograms
whoa It's a lot more it's electric cars
electric cars are [__] up the
environment
oh no isn't that like what a conundrum
life is I mean it's not just the
environment it's like I'm what I'm
saying the environment I'm like the
frequency of the earth yes you know like
you're until somebody cleans that up the
the minds and until somebody actually
looks like every electronic thing with
Lithium-ion batteries is connected to
this horrific crime against humanity
yeah what are we doing nothing nothing
Wild
all the chitter chatter all the talk
about equality and equity and helping
and charity and what about that we're
all not a personally responsible yeah
bro this ain't a secret it's not like a
[__] x marks a spot in a pirate map
nope this is Google yeah Google and yeah
I has the Darth car on my podcast we
talked about it in front of [__]
millions of people people know it's a
thing yeah and they're not they're not
even talking about it they're not doing
[__] it's inconvenient it's too
inconvenient to care about it's very
inconvenient yeah for all of us yeah
we're not going to stop using our phones
Idaho cell phone company
you gonna start it
that should be the name of the company
Idaho cell phone company dude they mine
they mine Cobalt
let's build like this would if Apple was
smart did make a deal okay like you buy
iPhone you can buy iPhone Pro iPhone Pro
Max you could buy that or you could buy
Idaho cell phone company iPhone iPhone
okay it cost two thousand dollars but
it's made in [__] Idaho and you get
to see the photos of the people that
work in the factory
and you know that everybody's getting
paid well and everybody has health
insurance
[Music]
you know you would do it of course 100
it would be a big status thing to have
the Idaho cell phone company's iPhone
yes but that is good that that is good
we reward caring about other people 100
we want that we want that
ICC I see see Idaho cell phone company
this is old school just a [__] flip
phone like uh uh the state of Idaho like
the way it's on the map like on the back
just says ICC and everybody go to ICC oh
[__] cool bro helping out the
environment